hi my name is Lisa Raye and I'm a
developer advocate at Google today I'll
show you how to implement sliding tabs
like the ones you may have seen in the
Google Play Store this is what we'll end
up with you can see the tab indicator
moves smoothly from tab to tab providing
continuous touch feedback as the user
Scrolls the first step is the layout you
need two things tabs on the top and a
view pager on the bottom make sure to
use the full package name for the
sliding tab layout because the custom
view included in our project next will
follow a specific order to set them up
find your view pager and set its adapter
and then second set the view pager on
the sliding tab layout the last thing to
do is to implement the adapter for your
view pager you can do whatever you want
here just make sure to override get page
title the view pager calls this method
in the adapter to get the title that's
shown for each tab here I'm generating
it based on item position let's look at
another example where each tab is a
different color the tabs take care of
blending the colors together for you as
you transition from each tab as you can
see the messages tab is red and the
photos tab is yellow but the indicator
when it's halfway between them is orange
to start this example first I'm
initializing some simple data for my
pager this is just a list of simple
objects that hold a string title and
indicator color and a divider color next
I'll set up the views this time I'm
using a fragment state pager adapter you
can use any adapter you'd normally use
with a view pager again remember to set
the adapter first before you set the
view pager on the sliding tab layout now
I'm going to set a tab colorizer
on the sliding tab layout it's going to
use the stored color in the list of
items I created and make that the
indicator color for the tab it does the
same thing for the divider color the
divider color applies to divider on the
right side of the tab in our example the
dividers are all gray but they could
even be different colors if you need a
very colorful tab layout be sure to
check out the sliding tabs basic and
sliding tabs colored samples for the
full working code of these samples which
is linked in the description along with
these slides thanks for watching